comment j'explique les ghetto je crois
bah je lui ai dit de toute façon moi
j'ai appris par hasard que c'était aux
allées du parc que les homos se
rencontraient
pas ailleurs parce qu'il y a pas
d'autres endroits on définitive
10h du matin sur le marché de 10 jours
distribution de tracts pour la marche
nationale des homosexuels et des
lesbiennes à Paris le 19 juin signe des
temps ou volonté des homos de sortir du
ghetto ils acceptent d'être filmés et de
répondre à nos questions à visage
découvert l'occasion aussi pour nous de
voir comment est perçu le phénomène
homosexuel dans une ville de province
au
[Musique]
en parler ça rentre bien dans les mœurs
c'est vraiment un truc actuel bon on va
ma foi c'est bien avancer on en parlait
pas maintenant ça existe on en parle bah
moi je trouve ça très bien qu'est-ce que
vous pensez les homosexuels
personnellement ça me dérange absolument
pas
moi
de mon côté ça va si tout le monde ça va
tant mieux quoi oh moi je trouve ça très
bien
j'ai pas besoin de parler de ça moi j'ai
65 ans
ça me personnellement ça me dérange pas
on est en côtoie tous les jours dans
notre boulot alors
je m'entends la mauvaise exemple à la
jeunesse ah ça c'est mon collègue c'est
ça
ils sont libres de leur corps
ils sont libres dans leur vie
et je suis je suis quelqu'un qui veut
avoir
tout le monde qu'ils ont le tout leur
droit et
une heure
et leur liberté ça vous choque non vous
savez maintenant moi je trouve que c'est
bien c'est la vie quand c'est tout c'est
la vie comme ça toute façon elle est
trop courte pour s'emmerder
au 23 de la rue Charles le Téméraire le
seul lieu de rencontre homosexuelle de
la ville Diane et Adrien les homo aussi
retrouvent le soir pour discuter être
ensemble et vivre autant que possible
leur homosexualité en toute liberté
après les vif polémiques déclenchées par
sa création le local aujourd'hui a
plutôt tendance à se banaliser doucement
on devient homosexuel ou on est
homosexuel
je pense qu'on le devient
comment ça se fait pas c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser
je pense que
l'éducation
par exemple
je me suis toujours sentie homosexuel
c'est difficile
de savoir où et quand ça a pu commencer
j'avais jamais essayé d'analyser le
phénomène
ça vous intéresse pas
non je suis comme ça
mourir
idiote alors si un jour je trouve que
j'ai l'occasion de le faire je le ferai
au départ c'était un groupe de copains
de copines qui avaient besoin de se
retrouver ensemble pour discuter de leur
vécu c'est un peu un groupe de
conscience avec l'aspect échange
d'informations et on a réussi à puiser
là-dedans un petit peu la force
nécessaire pour arriver à s'affirmer à
s'assumer à vivre comme homosexuel ce
qui est pas facile parce que il y a la
répression la culpabilité le flic dans
notre tête plein de choses comme ça qui
étaient présentes et il a fallu des
emmener je dirais pour commencer en
discuter un petit peu avec nos proches
notre famille puis avec des groupes des
groupes politiques ou syndicaux le
planning familial etc on a eu toute une
série d'échanges de ce type là et on en
arrive finalement à mener toute une
série de campagnes contre la répression
les interdictions professionnelles les
licenciements les tabassages par les
flics il ouvre etc
mais je dirais au-delà de ces aspects de
lutte anti-répression il y a aussi la
question de d'un vécu en positif
c'est-à-dire on voudrait arriver à dire
et à faire en sorte que un homosexuel ne
lesbienne puisse être bien dans sa peau
puis cette épanouie vivre une relation
de couple un peu harmonieuse se sentir
libre donc arriver finalement à
construire un peu quelque chose et je
crois pouvoir dire que cet aspect là de
la lutte dépasse finalement la seule
question les homosexuels qui est déjà un
truc important il y a trois quatre
millions d'homosexuels en France c'est
pas une toute petite minorité
négligeable mais si vous voulez au-delà
les gens hétérosexuels ou qui se
croient-elles ou qu'on dit-elle ont
souvent aussi des problèmes avec leur
sexualité et même leur homosexualité on
en parle très peu c'est vrai que la
sexualité c'est les alcôves c'est le
toubib c'est le confessionnal mais bon
alors qu'en fait c'est quelque chose de
très important évidemment dans dans la
vie des gens et nous on voudrait dans la
lancée un petit peu d'ailleurs du
mouvement des femmes qui a commencé à
partir du viol de toute une série de
questions à poser des problèmes de
sexualité sans vous ferez un peu dans
cette brèche et faire comprendre aux
gens que c'est quelque chose de très
important et peut-être arriver à uré un
petit peu aussi à la libération des
hétérosexuels comment ça s'est passé
avec vos parents
au départ disons que j'étais obligé de
les mettre devant le fait accompli et
leur faire une sorte de chantage c'est à
dire c'est moi ou c'est rien c'est moi
comme je suis au sérieux
ça a été oui
si vous aviez un fils ou une fille
homosexuelle comment est-ce que vous
réagiriez pas de problème
si il veut choisir une autre voix il
prend une autre voix mais j'y fasse je
lui dirai que c'est pas bien je dirais
que malgré tout bah il y a peut-être des
inconvénients je suis pressentir
puisqu'il veut pas Inès et celui que j'y
fasse de toute façon moi je trouve que
dans la vie il faut laisser faire les
gens toute façon il se rendra compte par
lui mais de toute façon les expériences
des autres n'ont jamais servi à personne
comment allez-vous réagi lorsque vous
avez appris que votre fils se homosexuel
je pense que dans ce genre de choses et
on doit l'accepter pour moi l'important
c'est qu'il s'accepte lui-même qui garde
son équilibre et qu'il soit heureux à sa
façon même si ce n'est pas la mienne à
vrai dire c'est son bonheur qui est le
plus important
n'a pas eu un moment de surprise ça fait
un choc un peu tout de même sur le
moment je la mettre enfin
du moment que c'était ça son bonheur il
fallait qu'il vive sa sexualité
comment l'avez-vous appris
un peu compte malgré tout et petit à
petit j'ai compris que c'était ça ça
veut dire que vous avez déjà des
rapports très confiants avec votre fils
et je crois que depuis qui c'est
vraiment confiée à moi on s'est encore
rapproché davantage parce que c'est il
sait que je le comprends et que je ne
fais rien contre lui au contraire je
l'aiderai je l'épaulerai le plus
possible
celui-ci dans un lieu de rencontre
homosexuel vous y venez régulièrement
pas très régulièrement je viens surtout
pour lui faire plaisir et en fait
également pour parler à d'autres qui eux
n'ont pas toujours la chance d'avoir une
mère à qui il peut se confier alors mon
fils il y a un jour même mon mari si
jeune arrive si un jour il me dit j'ai
rencontré il me disait ça bah je dirais
même pas
jalouse déjà pour plus de ça si ça lui
dit ben écoute tant ton expérience tu
verras bien pourquoi pas
un soir chez Dion et Adrien notre
présence ne semble gêner personne et
nous abordons alors la question des
ghettos homosexuels
pourquoi pas aller ailleurs
même si on le fait
pour casser du [__] puis faire leur
portefeuille moi il viennent en bande en
général picassée du PIB casser du [__]
quoi ça fait virer pour se défoule et
maintenant petite copine ça arrive aussi
alors ils sont encore plus beaucoup plus
agressif parce qu'ils veulent se rendre
encore beaucoup plus viril à côté de
leur copine bon ils sont des chaînes en
plus on fait le portefeuille on peut
passer une bonne soirée à bon compte
pour eux il y a toujours le mythe du
[__] friquet j'imagine que être homo ça
veut dire avoir de l'argent ça les
attire la police aussi oui la police
vient faire des contrôles il y a des
loubards donc il y a des qui viennent
pour les loups
au début de la soirée aux allées du parc
le lieu de drague le plus connu des
homosexuels de Dijon le ghetto comme il
le disent même pas de femme ou très
rarement mais dès la nuit tombée un
balai incessant de voiture et de
promeneurs entre guillemets
pourquoi les lieux de drague homosexuels
sont-ils toujours liés ou pissotières
moi je crois qu'au niveau des
vespasiennes des pistottières ou les
tasses tout dépend comment on les
appelle on s'appelle même aussi des
chapelles bon je crois qu'il y a tout un
tas de fantasmes qui est lié autour je
trouve que des gens aiment bien les mecs
aiment bien faire l'amour dans les
tasses ma foi c'est leur problème quand
je pense moi personnellement je les
ferai grandir
je préfère
je préfère aborder les gens comme ça
discute avec les gens comme ça ailleurs
que là quoi et comment vous expliquer
ces ghettos
comment j'explique les ghettos je crois
je vous l'ai dit toute façon moi j'ai
appris par hasard que vous avez du parc
que les homos se rencontraient
pas ailleurs parce qu'il y a pas
d'autres endroits on définitive on ne
peut pas c'est très difficile de
rencontrer quelqu'un dans la rue parce
qu'on sait jamais à qui on a affaire
tandis qu'ici bon bah on sait que 90% de
l'équipe qui sont ici vont sont au moins
on sait qu'il y a à qui on a fait
je crois que c'est pour ça qu'on se
retrouve à peu près tous ici
[Musique]
et l'amour là-dedans l'amour l'amour
c'est comme partout la majorité des
homosexuels vivent en couple et s'ils le
font ce qu'il sait mais ils ont qu'une
contrainte ils sont il ne reste pas
ensemble à cause des pressions de la
belle-famille des enfants de la baraque
du divorce et tout c'est bien parce que
je trouve qu'ils sont bien ensemble
alors il y a l'amour passion il y a
l'amour romantique que l'amour calmer
tranquille de l'amour qui dure toute une
vie d'amour possessif il y a la jalousie
la tendresse il y a les lendemains aussi
de rupture avec les difficultés il y a
la vie quoi finalement telle qu'elle
existe partout
[Musique]